un bon soir tel ventura mercier d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france est
donc un jugement historique qui a été
rendu à minneapolis va-t-il marquer un
tournant dans l'histoire des états unis
c'est une très bonne question
effectivement c'est historique
véritablement historique
ce n'est que la première étape est un
très long marathon qui passe par une
chaîne montagneuse afin de renverser le
racisme institutionnel qui existe dans
la justice dans la police et dans la
société en général aux états unis la non
de la culpabilité de langue slovène a
fait réagir de nombreuses personnalités
1 bill clinton barack obama joe biden on
l'a vu dans ce sujet qui est même allé
jusqu'à dire qu'il aime répandre la
famille de georges floyd dans ses bras
c'était étonnant aux états unis ce parti
pris affiché par des personnalités sur
une décision de justice ces réactions
quoi qu'on en pense inde ne sont elles
pas politique mais une question si
importante ce qui est arrivé l'été
dernier à minneapolis et manifestations
historiques qui ont été organisées après
de toute façon et faisait qu'il
s'agirait un sujet politique
nos hommes et femmes politiques nos
dirigeants doivent refléter l'état de la
société
je ne pense pas que là le sujet a été
politisée je pense que le racisme
a été un problème aux états unis depuis
très longtemps qui nous a accompagnés
dans notre politique dans notre culture
dans tout ce que nous faisons donc je ne
pense pas qu'ils aient tort de
s'exprimer surtout lorsque c'est
intervenue après le verdict mais comme
tout sujet aux états unis la politique
s'empare du sujet bien sûr est notamment
lorsqu'il s'agit de communauté opprimée
qui ont donc des bénéfices et des
inconvénients
alors ce n'est pas fini parce que on
attend encore le verdict qui tombera à
la peine en tout cas la sentence dans
huit semaines ça va être également très
suivie très attendu à quoi faut-il
s'attendre selon vous se veut peut-être
vie semaine très intéressant l'équipe la
défense de derek chauvin va bien sûr
faire appel
on ne sait pas s'il va vraiment devoir
purger cette peine qui arrive à y voir
donc des appels
j'appelle il faudra par le résultat tout
cela il est important de se rendre
compte que statistiquement en moyenne
c'est un cas de figure très rare un
officier qui a été condamné et qui va
également recevoir une condamnation une
mois peine c'est très rare depuis 2005
il y a eu 81 17 cas où un officier de
police s'est retrouvé devant les
tribunaux après une fusillade et seules
celles ci sont arrivés ont complété le
procès il n'y a eu que cette
condamnation
en moyenne les policiers au niveau des
statistiques bénéficient d'une impunité
car il y a à peu près d'après les
statistiques au moins
mille physiatre par an donc c'est un cas
de figure extrêmement rare et à l'avenir
tout cas il faut y aller un jour à la
fois une semaine à la fois et il est
certain que derek chauvin va faire appel
il faudra donc voir ce qui arrive
ensuite merci beaucoup telle aventure à
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france soir